[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os pregunto por la capital mundial
del juego y pensáis en las vegas' estáis
muy equivocados el centro mundial del
juego el corazón el enclave más
importante de la industria de los
casinos no está en nevada sino a unos
6000 kilómetros de distancia de la
conocida como ciudad del pecado estoy
refiriendo por supuesto a la antigua
colonia portuguesa de macao veréis como
seguramente la mayoría ya sepáis macao
es una pequeña ciudad situada en la
desembocadura del río de las perlas en
la costa sureste de china a tan sólo 60
km de hong kong y como esta última
aunque está bajo soberanía china
mantiene un amplio grado de autonomía
bajo el modelo un país dos sistemas
mccaw tiene sus propias aduanas su
propia moneda y sus propias leyes de tal
forma que por poner un ejemplo mientras
que en el internet chino nos encontramos
con la gran muralla un enorme
cortafuegos que impide acceder a sitios
como youtube google o facebook entre
otros muchos los macaenses al igual que
les ocurre a los hongkoneses están
libres de todas estas restricciones pero
realmente si por algo destaca este
enclave es por ser el territorio con más
densidad de población de todo el mundo
más de 23 mil personas por kilómetro
cuadrado y también por haberse
convertido en apenas unos años en uno de
los lugares más ricos de todo el planeta
amigos hechas números con una superficie
de apenas 33 kilómetros cuadrados lo que
supone 27 veces menos que la de berlín o
18 veces menos que la de madrid y con
una población de algo menos de 700 mil
habitantes este lugar logró en 2019 un
pib superior a los 50 mil millones de
dólares es decir 177 mil dólares per
cápita esto lo convierte en el
territorio autónomo más rico de toda
asia en el cuarto del mundo tan sólo por
detrás de mónaco liechtenstein y
luxemburgo
[Música]
hablamos de un lugar tan particular que
gracias a todo este enorme crecimiento
económico ha visto crecer su superficie
terrestre en un 65% en apenas unas pocas
décadas sí sí un 65% y no lo ha hecho
mediante conquistas ni nada por el
estilo
macao es un territorio donde podéis
creerme cada metro cuadrado cuenta y
para poder crecer le está ganando
terreno al mar aquí podéis ver por
ejemplo las últimas ampliaciones que se
están realizando en las cuales está
previsto que durante los próximos años
se construyan más de 35.000 nuevas
viviendas además de hoteles centros
comerciales y todo tipo de instalaciones
pero esa no es su única característica
particular macao también es considerado
como un alumno aventajado y es que
veréis al igual que hong kong la antigua
colonia portuguesa fue devuelta a china
a finales del siglo 20 en este caso
concreto en 1999 también como hemos
dicho bajo el modelo un país dos
sistemas
[Música]
sin embargo a diferencia de hong kong el
sentimiento de pertenencia china aquí es
mucho más fuerte según las encuestas
mientras que la mayoría de los
hongkoneses y sienten exactamente eso
hong kong es ese macao la mayoría de los
ciudadanos se sienten también chinos tal
vez tenga algo que ver que en este caso
más de la mitad de los residentes han
nacido en la china continental pero eso
no es todo mientras que en hong kong la
lucha las protestas para mantener su
estatus de libertad han sido frecuentes
desde la transferencia del territorio a
china en macau las cosas han sido muy
pero que muy distintas en 2009 este
territorio adoptó por su cuenta su
propia ley de seguridad nacional más
laxa que la aprobada ahora en hong kong
pero con un espíritu similar además
durante todos estos años las
manifestaciones contra chinas se han
reprimido el uso de los sistemas de
vigilancia y reconocimiento facial es
cada vez mayor que incluso se ha
prohibido el acceso a numerosos
legisladores abogados activistas y
académicos pro democracia de hong kong
digamos que la idea es que en macao las
libertades civiles están relativamente
reconocidas mientras eso si no uses
meterte con la madre china si lo haces
entonces no esperes compasión es por eso
que en pekín siempre han considerado a
este lugar como un buen alumno frente al
rebelde hong kong pero queridos amigos
dicho esto hoy en visual política
hablamos de macao por dos motivos
primero porque este pequeño territorio
ha sido quizás la economía de todo el
mundo a la que más duro le ha impactado
la pandemia del coronavirus para que os
hagáis una idea se estima que en 2020 el
pib ha caído más de un 50 por ciento si
lo habéis escuchado bien un 50 por
ciento eso sí que es una debacle un
batacazo una hecatombe un hecho de
obligado comentario en visual político
nos parece y el segundo motivo tiene
mucho que ver con la industria
financiera de hong kong en concreto con
los deseos de pekín de convertir a macao
una plaza financiera internacional de
primer nivel en un pasado vídeo ya os
comentábamos todo lo que la economía
china seguía dependiendo de hong kong
así que tenemos unas cuantas preguntas
que está pasando con la economía de
macao que explica la salvaje caída de
más del 50 por ciento del pib qué planes
tiene china para este pequeño territorio
amigos vamos a contestar a estas
cuestiones pero antes antes veamos cómo
ha cambiado macao bajo la soberanía
china atentos
[Música]
de portugal a china el día 20 de
diciembre del 99 casi casi en el nuevo
siglo
macao separado de portugal para
convertirse en parte de la república
popular de china había estado bajo
administración portuguesa ni más ni
menos que 442 años en ese momento en
1999 caura una ciudad de unos
cuatrocientos cuarenta mil habitantes
tenía una superficie de poco más de 23
kilómetros cuadrados y recibía como
importante enclave comercial que era 7
millones de visitantes cada año
mack ahora un lugar relativamente rico
si lo comparamos con sus vecinos a
excepción claro está de hong kong
sin embargo lo mejor estaba aún por
llegar
[Música]
ese día 20 de diciembre del 99 no solo
se produjo un cambio de soberanía sino
que también se dio el pistoletazo de
salida a un cambio frenético un cambio
que transformaría por completo el tejido
social la estructura económica e incluso
la geografía de este lugar en pocos años
ha marcado no le van a conocer ni sus
propios habitantes en apenas 20 años
entre el 99 y el 2019 la población de
macao que decía más de un 50% su
superficie en más de un 40% el número de
visitantes se multiplicó prácticamente
por 6 y su pib pasó de unos 6.500
millones de dólares a más de 50 mil todo
en apenas 20 años
además el desempleo prácticamente no
existe e incluso el gobierno de macao no
solo no tiene deuda pública cero sino
que acumula unas reservas financieras de
más de 65.000 millones de dólares
estadounidenses gracias a los cuantiosos
superávits que ha ido acumulando año
tras año
[Música]
amigos la clave de este éxito está en un
protagonista más importante para esta
transformación de lo que marlon brando
lo fue para el padrino la industria del
juego desde que se liberalizó en el año
2002 una enorme una gigantesca lluvia de
miles de millones de dólares en
inversiones e ingresos públicos cayó
sobre macao en poco tiempo se
construyeron descomunales complejos
turísticos con hoteles y casinos de
hecho tres de los mayores cinco casinos
de todo el mundo están precisamente aquí
en esta ciudad para que os hagáis una
idea la industria del juego facturó en
marcado 36 mil millones de dólares
cuatro veces más que en las vegas' sisi
cuatro veces más
sin embargo esperando un momento porque
houston tenemos un problema
[Música]
las cosas han ido viento en popa durante
estos 20 años sí pero todo prácticamente
todo ha estado vinculado a los casinos
sí es verdad junto a ellos y gracias a
los más de 40 millones de turistas que
han terminado llegando a la ciudad cada
año se abrieron hoteles restaurantes
servicios de transporte etcétera
etcétera pero amigos prácticamente toda
la diversificación ha sido vertical es
decir se ha producido con negocios que
abastecen a los casinos o que brindan
servicios a los propios jugadores pero
no ha ido más allá y la pregunta que
podemos que debemos hacernos es hasta
qué punto macao es dependiente del juego
[Música]
en 2019 la industria del juego fue
responsable de más de la mitad del pib
de mccaw pero si además sumamos los
negocios que son en gran medida
dependientes del juego como los hoteles
y los restaurantes entonces podemos
decir que directa o indirectamente la
industria del juego responsable de más
del 60 por ciento de la economía de
macao y no sólo eso además el propio
gobierno depende de los ingresos del
juego y es que el 85 por ciento de lo
que ingresa al gobierno es decir más de
8 de cada 10 patacas la moneda de macau
procede del sector del juego
[Música]
una dependencia simple y llanamente
gigantesca el problema el problema es
haber otra pregunta que he hecho
imprevisto ha ocurrido durante el 2020
321 creo que todos habéis acertado el
coronavirus y que ha provocado el
coronavirus pues por ejemplo que el
turismo internacional se hundiera que
los hoteles tuvieran que cerrar durante
mucho tiempo o que la crisis económica
haya castigado duramente los bolsillos
de millones de personas amigos la
industria del ocio y el turismo ha sido
una de las más perjudicadas y con ella
también la de los casinos atentos al que
probablemente ha sido el mayor impacto
económico del coronavirus en todo el
mundo
[Música]
la mayor recesión económica del mundo
2020 ha sido un año muy duro para todos
no creo que tenga que convencerlos de
esta idea la crisis sanitaria las
cientos y cientos de miles de víctimas
la crisis económica
en fin 2020 pasará a la historia como un
año terrible pero amigos si hablamos de
crisis impacto económico y recesión
macao se lleva la palma si la ciudad ya
sufrió un duro golpe cuando en 2015 el
gobierno de xi jinping empezó a
perseguir la corrupción en china 2020 ha
sido superador pesadilla el número de
visitantes se ha desplomado un 90% los
ingresos de los casinos se han hundido y
con ellos también la recaudación del
gobierno
y el resultado es que para macao el 2020
ha sido toda una debacle económica su
pib ha caído más de un 50 por ciento un
50 por ciento es con mucha diferencia la
mayor recesión de todo el mundo
[Música]
los casinos están perdiendo cientos y
cientos de millones de dólares los
hoteles y los restaurantes ya han
quedado vacíos el gobierno ha tenido que
rescatar a la aerolínea nacional
y encima la economía china su principal
cliente se ha desacelerado con mucha
fuerza el para colmo ahí no termina todo
además algunos países como camboya han
anunciado nuevos incentivos para traer
la industria del juego como una vía para
superar la crisis
amigos y en macao tenían pocas dudas de
que la dependencia del juego era un
problema ahora están completamente
seguros sin embargo la dependencia lejos
de reducirse es cada vez mayor el peso
del sector del juego en la economía
local ha seguido aumentando desde el
2016 y es aquí donde surge una palabra
clave en el término de moda el mensaje
perseguido por todos los políticos de la
ciudad la diversificación esto es lograr
que la economía de macao vaya mucho más
allá del juego convertirse en un centro
de eventos deportivos convenciones
espectáculos servicios profesionales
servicios médicos nuevas tecnologías y
estudiantes extranjeros y también por
qué no desarrollar un auténtico distrito
financiero y esto esto es algo amigos
que tiene mucho que ver con la tensa
situación que se está viviendo en hong
kong atentos
nasdaq chinos
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas de visual
político macao y hong kong como ya os
contamos en un pasado vídeo tienen
respecto a china unas características
muy especiales
a diferencia del gigante asiático estos
dos territorios permiten el libre
movimiento de capital tienen monedas
vinculadas directa o indirectamente al
dólar estadounidense cuentan con
tribunales y supervisores independientes
e incluso una legislación de mercado
equiparable a la de los países
occidentales
y eso es precisamente lo que ha hecho
que hong kong tal y como os contamos sea
la tercera mayor plaza financiera de
todo el planeta tierra tan solo por
detrás de nueva york y londres y es
también lo que explica que la economía
china necesite los servicios de la
industria financiera de hong kong para
captar dólares poner a resguardo la
pasta el capital e invertir el
extranjero o recibir inversiones sin
embargo bueno que os voy a contar los
que seguimos al político ya sabéis cómo
están las cosas por esos lares
durante el 2020 china ha ejecutado la
ocupación de hong kong y las relaciones
entre ambos territorios son tan
difíciles que bien podrían copar todas
las portadas de las revistas del corazón
y por eso en pekín la animadversión por
la ex colonia británica es más alta que
nunca ya no están del todo cómodos con
la dependencia que la economía china
sigue teniendo de hong kong por eso
precisamente por eso muchos han querido
buscar una alternativa y recordáis quién
es el alumno aventajado exacto macao y
por su parte en la ex colonia portuguesa
tienen una palabra que no se quitan de
la cabeza diversificación así que uno
más uno dos los intereses encajan así
que dicho y hecho
en 2016 el gobierno chino anunció que
apoyaría la creación de un centro
financiero en macao y dos años más tarde
en 2018 el nam gwon group un holding de
inversiones del propio gobierno chino
creó la llonga mccaw financial asset
exchange company también conocida como
el mox una bolsa de bonos y deuda una
bolsa en la que ya se han emitido y ccoo
digan por ejemplo bonos del gobierno de
china de la provincia de guangzhou o de
varias empresas públicas del gigante
asiático evidentemente todavía es una
bolsa muy pequeña pero ya se considera
el tercer mercado de bonos más grande de
todo asia pero eso no es todo ahora el
siguiente objetivo es lanzar una bolsa
similar al nasdaq norteamericano
cotizada en yuanes donde puedan captar
financiación y cotizar las empresas
tecnológicas de la conocida como área de
la gran bahía una región en la que
encontramos a hong kong macao y también
por ejemplo a la capital tecnológica de
china shenzhen la pregunta es conseguir
a macao convertirse en un nuevo centro
financiero internacional pues
lo cierto es que a día de hoy parece
difícil
[Música]
los grandes centros financieros
necesitan muchos profesionales
especializados una normativa muy
desarrollada supervisores con
experiencia etcétera etcétera y macao
por no tener casi no tiene ni terreno
para construir nuevas instalaciones y
además sorprendentemente la diferencia
de hong kong no ha sido un terreno
particularmente abierto a la atracción
de profesionales extranjeros
así que ya lo veis hoy por hoy no parece
una misión sencilla pero ojo porque
ahora mismo los intereses de china y
macao son coincidentes y sabemos ha
demostrado el gigante asiático es que
suele ser perseverantes el régimen
fiscal en macau es simple y con bajos
impuestos una razón por la que muchos
inversores quieren venir a macao algunas
empresas de china continental quieren
establecer su sede aquí mccaw tiene que
mejorar sus instalaciones y servicios de
oficina para retener a las grandes
empresas y desarrollar un distrito
central de negocios joyas en jefe
ejecutivo de macao pero este no es el
único proyecto que marca o tiene para
crecer y lograr diversificar su economía
otro de los objetivos que tiene por
ejemplo es desarrollar una industria
turística que no dependa del juego pero
claro si quieres atraer turistas pues
tienes que darles un motivo para ir ya
sean centros comerciales parques
temáticos centros de ocio instalaciones
culturales nuevos hoteles etcétera
etcétera y si quieren atraer empresas
pues tres cuartas partes de lo mismo
hace falta espacio pero en macao
prácticamente ya no hay sitio entonces
la pregunta
es como lograrlo
pues amigos si te has quedado sin
terreno y necesitas grandes extensiones
que puedes hacer pues por qué no
alquilar lo pues sabéis que eso es en
cierto modo lo que están haciendo
macao ha llegado a un acuerdo con la
ciudad china de hai para desarrollar
conjuntamente la isla de hanjin una isla
de 106 kilómetros cuadrados es decir
tres veces más grande que macao la idea
es convertir a jen ching en una especie
de zona económica especial con sus
propias normas y que albergue los
espacios que más superficie necesitan
como por ejemplo parques temáticos
universidades técnicas parques
tecnológicos o estadios deportivos así
como el acceso a la red china de alta
velocidad oa la red de autopistas
[Música]
sin ir más lejos el nuevo campus de la
universidad de macao por ejemplo ya está
en la isla las inversiones que el
gobierno de macao pretende realizar en
jaén ching son mil millonarias
en una situación ideal macao podría ser
un centro para bancos bufetes de
abogados y operaciones para algunas de
las 500 principales empresas del mundo
mientras que hanjin podría acomodar las
operaciones internas de estas empresas y
otras francolí director gerente de la
inmobiliaria savills macao yen team será
el orlando de china macao es las vegas'
hong kong es nueva york en una hora
puedes tenerlos todos larry le un
ejecutivo de la y sanz en fin este es el
panorama que se está viviendo en macao
en único territorio junto a hong kong
administrado por el modelo un país dos
sistemas una ciudad que ha logrado
convertirse en apenas 20 años en uno de
los lugares más prósperos de la tierra
que ha sufrido el mayor impacto
económico por la pandemia y que ahora
lucha por reciclarse la pregunta es lo
conseguirá te ves pasando unas
vacaciones en macao como siempre déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios si este
vídeo os ha parecido interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros a visual política una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]